there are several reasons as to why you
would want to learn a new skill
it could be for a job or simply acquire
a new talent
either way learning a new skill is very
rewarding it will keep you updated and
eventually be beneficial in the long run
however from the plethora of skills
available today how will you know which
skill to learn
not to worry here we are to help you
with that
welcome to yet another interesting and
informative video by simplylearn
in this video we will take you through
the top 10 skills for 2022.
before we get started make sure that you
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
the first skill on our list is data
science
over the past decade the data generated
from companies and individuals like us
is enormous
as for statista.com the global data
generated and consumed has grown from
two zeta bytes in 2010 to 79 zettabytes
in 2021. there's a need for companies to
make use of this data to drive their
business hence data science skills are
needed to interpret analyze visualize
and build predictive models
you should have knowledge about machine
learning algorithms statistics and deep
learning data scientists are in huge
demand in almost every sector such as
healthcare banking and e-commerce data
scientists are some of the highest paid
professionals in the world the average
salary of a data scientist in the us is
over 115 thousand dollars per annum the
second skill we have is web development
the web development field is always
evolving web developers help design and
develop interesting web-based
applications
they are the ones who take care of the
further development maintenance and
optimization of the existing websites
there is an increasing demand for
front-end and back-end developers in
almost every company that has its
presence online
you need to know html css javascript
react and angularjs to become a
successful web developer
a web developer in the united states
earns an average annual salary of 79
863 dollars
moving on to the third skill we have ux
design
since we are all working in a digital
world the user experiences on a website
or application has become extremely
crucial with companies looking to
increase customer interaction on their
website so that they spend ample time on
their platforms user experience
designers need to design products and
digital services that makes people's
lives more convenient and easier the
primary job of a ux designer is
researching how users behave and
interact with a product as per
indeed.com the average salary of a ux
designer in the united states is
eighty nine thousand three thirty four
dollars per annum
the fourth skill in the list of top 10
skills for 2022 is digital marketing
companies around the globe are
constantly increasing their budgets for
digital marketing because they recognize
that it has the potential to overtake
traditional marketing its popularity has
grown over the years with everything
being completely relocated to the
internet digital marketers help
companies rank their products on google
create interesting content for their
customers promote their products and
services on social media platforms and
also collaborate with vendors to enhance
their growth
if you are looking for a career in
digital marketing then you need to learn
seo sem content marketing social media
marketing as well as email marketing
a skilled digital marketer in the us
earns over 61
to 35 dollars per annum
the fifth skill on our list is cyber
security cyber security is a fascinating
branch of information technology this
field is highly lucrative in the current
times more than ever with business
moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the importance of cyber security
is on the rise
hence there is a high demand for cyber
security experts who can safeguard
digital data
without a good cyber security
infrastructure your company can't
protect itself against data breach
operations
this makes your company an easy target
for fraudsters
if you are looking for a career in cyber
security you need to have knowledge on
operating systems computer networking
and a few programming languages
taking up a relevant cyber security
certification will help you grow in your
cybersecurity career companies are
currently looking for skilled
cybersecurity experts who can advance
their cybersecurity measures according
to gartner the worldwide information
security market is forecast to reach
170.4 billion dollars in 2022. as per
pay scale the average salary of a cyber
security engineer in the united states
is ninety seven thousand eight zero four
dollars per annum
the next skill we have is coding coding
is one of the most important skills you
need to have if you are looking for a
tech job it's a valuable skill that
developers need to possess as we move to
a tech economy if you are a beginner in
coding then you should start with the
basics of one programming language
preferably python or c plus plus
software development jobs are on the
rise the increasing demand for software
applications and mobile apps is driving
this growth there is also a greater need
for network engineers and testers to
learn coding in order to automate manual
tasks the average salary of a software
developer in the united states is ninety
seven thousand seven eighty three
dollars per year at number seven we have
project management
in today's fast growing world most of
the projects are not completed on time
due to a lack of proper planning
resources and execution
there is a need for project management
skills that can help teams focus on
providing the right values for their
employers
with project management skills you can
reduce costs delivery time and increase
revenue project management also teaches
you how to create communicate and
execute a project plan
you should have a solid knowledge of
project management methodologies such as
agile scrum prince2 and also have a good
understanding of risk management and
cost management
a project manager in the united states
earns eighty eight thousand nine zero
seven dollars per annum
the eighth skill in our list of top ten
skills for 2022 we have video editing
with more and more people starting to
rely on videos as their primary sources
of information
this creates excellent opportunities for
video editors and content creators
video is more interactive than text or
image based media hence professional
level video editors are becoming
increasingly in demand
according to the us bureau of labor
statistics the employment of video and
film editors is expected to grow by 29
from 2020 to 20 30. as for glassdoor
video editors in the us earn over 65
660 dollars per year
next on our list is a soft skill and
that is decision making
there isn't a day that goes by without
us having to make a decision right
some of these decisions we make are
spontaneous and some are not
decision making is the process of
choosing the best option from a set of
options however how to arrive at the
best option is quite brainstorming
making smart judgments is a necessary
life skill not only for being successful
but also for achieving personal
fulfillment hence it's important to
master this skill
before making a decision remember to
gauge the situation well and weigh the
pros and cons
skillful decision making always enhances
the chance of a positive outcome
and the final skill we have on our list
is communication
we are in 2022 and it is high time you
improve your communication skills and
understand its relevance in today's age
good communication skills will take you
a long way in both your professional and
personal life
how you behave and talk with people is
very crucial
for acing all the above mentioned skills
being good at communication is a must
however technically sound sure you are
if you are unable to explain yourself
with clarity it hampers your career
development
be it in any field sales or marketing or
id being a good communicator will help
you shine better
on that note it is vital to remember
that a good communicator is someone who
also possesses good listening skills
only if you are an attentive listener
will you be able to interpret messages
and speak well
eventually communication is a skill that
is going to help you become a good
leader
a leader who communicates positively
builds a positive mindset in people
so what are you waiting for develop your
communication skills as it will take you
a long way
with such significant skills to master
in the current time the future appears
to be brighter than ever
there is simply no stopping it do you
think we missed any important skill to
learn in 2022
let us know in the comment section below
thank you for being here and watch out
for more such informative videos from us
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here